hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
a square has a triangle inside of it
with lengths of four three and five
what is the value of x the length of the
square side
i've adapted this problem from one i saw
online
pause the video if you'd like to give it
a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve for x the length of
the square side
first notice that the triangle has
lengths of 3 4 and 5 and that means it's
a right triangle
the angle between the sides of 3 and 4
will be a right angle and measures 90
degrees
now let's focus on these two triangles
we're going to show that this triangle
is similar to this triangle
how can we do that
we're going to show that they have
exactly the same angles
to get started let's label this angle as
a degrees
here we have a right angle because we
have a square
therefore the remaining angle in this
square will be 90 degrees minus a
now let's calculate this angle here
we need it to be 180 degrees minus the
other two angles along this straight
line so this angle will be 180 degrees
minus the 90 degrees for the right angle
minus the other angle which is 90
degrees minus a
when we simplify this we just get a
degrees
now we have a right angle here in this
corner of the square
so the final angle in this triangle will
be 90 degrees minus a
we can see that corresponding angles of
these two triangles are equal and
therefore these two triangles are
similar
but how does that help us solve the
problem
well let's label the shorter side of
this triangle as y
since the entire side of the square is
equal to x this distance will be x minus
y
now we use the property that these two
triangles are similar
therefore the ratio of their long leg to
their hypotenuse will be equal
so x minus y all over 3 must be equal to
x over 4.
we'll solve this equation for y
we'll first cross multiply
then we'll distribute
then we'll simplify
we get x is equal to 4y which means y is
equal to x over 4.
we'll substitute that in to our diagram
here
we can now solve for x because we have a
right triangle and we're going to use
the distance formula
x squared plus the quantity x over 4
squared is equal to 4 squared
this means 17 over 16 x squared is equal
to 16
and for positive x we have a value that
x is equal to 16 all over the square
root of 17.
and that's the answer
it's a fun little geometry problem and i
hope you enjoyed it too
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
thanks for watching and thanks for your
support
[Music]
you